-Welcome back.
We are here with Zoe Kravitz,
everybody!
We're talking about
"The Batman"!
"The Batman's" out this weekend.
Fandom is huge.
Have you seen this
with an audience yet?
-I watched it last night
with an actual audience...
-You did.
-...at the premiere,
which is why
I'm so hungover right now.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean -- is it --
It must have been so exciting.
-It's amazing.
I mean, it's definitely
something you want
to watch on a big screen.
It's definitely something
you want to watch with people.
But it's a very --
it's an intense film,
and I think a lot of people walk
in going like, "Whoo, Batman!"
and they leave like,
"Whoa, Batman."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah.
Is that the reaction you're
getting so far from everybody?
-Yeah, I think people
are surprised
by how much depth
is in the story.
I think Matt
just did a really beautiful job
at grounding the characters
in the world of Gotham.
-And also, I like what they did.
Because you -- you are Catwoman,
but you're not actually --
I mean, you're not actually --
-Yeah, I'm not Catwoman yet.
-Yes.
-I'm Selina Kyle.
-You're not Catwoman yet.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, but I loved --
Can we say your mask?
-Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
-Your mask is basically just
a ski hat or a beanie...
-Yeah.
-...with a hole cut in it.
-And you look so cool.
[ Laughter ]
And I'm like,
"How does --"
That's why I lost the audition.
When I auditioned, I was like,
I did that,
And they were like,
"Dude, get lost."
[ Laughter ]
But, honestly, and --
and it's got little --
you got the cat ear --
-Very subtle little ears.
Yeah.
-But I was like, "Dude,
that's a great thing
'cause it's a mask
for someone who...
-Who doesn't have the means
to really make it.
-You're not Bruce Wayne.
-Yeah, exactly.
She's not Bruce Wayne.
-You're not a millionaire, yeah.
-And because she's not Catwoman
yet, Matt really wanted to
kind of have somewhere to go
so we can, you know,
get to the place
where we see the --
the Catwoman mask eventually.
But this is where it starts.
-Here's what
I liked about it, too,
'cause I always think of, like,
"Oh, Halloween."
-Oh, yeah.
Anyone can do it.
-Anyone can be...
-Buy a beanie.
-...you for Halloween.
-Yeah.
-Any ski hat you have,
cut a hole in the front,
and you're Catwoman
for Halloween.
-The only thing about that is,
if no one does it,
it's more offensive.
[ Laughter ]
-No, trust me.
Trust me,
everyone's gonna do it.
It's gonna be giant.
I could already tell, like,
"Oh, my gosh."
Plus, you look
so cool doing it.
-Aw, thanks.
-As only you can do.
Now, how do we set up
"The Batman"
for anyone who just --
you're going in cold turkey?
-Oh, man. Okay.
So, this is a detective story.
We're in year two
of Batman being Batman,
so it's not quite
an origin story,
but it's still the beginning.
Gotham is still --
-So the public doesn't really
know who is the Batman?
-Yeah, and the cops are like,
"Who is this guy?"
-"Do we trust this guy?"
-Yeah, yeah.
And there's a serial killer
in Gotham and he kind of
has to --
you know, he follows the --
the clues and figures out
who's -- what's going on.
And the clues lead him to
a nightclub where I work.
-Yeah.
Man, it's action, it's romance.
It's --
There's jokes in there.
It's just --
It's just great music.
-The music's amazing.
-It's dark, it's cool.
It's awesome.
It's just --
You guys are gonna love it.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Zoe Kravitz
and Robert Pattinson
in "The Batman."
Take a look.
[ Tumbler clicking, loud thunk ]
-You're pretty good at that.
♪♪
-Hey, gimme that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whoo!
Zoe Kravitz, everybody!
"The Batman" is in theaters
and IMAX this Friday.